4 no sé si se trata de una oleada o de
una nueva tendencia pero cada vez vemos
más modelos mestizos y negros en las
pasarelas cosa que antes no ocurría
absolutamente porque aportar una dosis
justa de diversidad Es realmente un
valor añadido tienes que entender que
seamos negras blancas asiáticas todas
hacemos el mismo trabajo y todas somos
mujeres hermosas no hay un tipo de mujer
que se adapte a este trabajo es un
trabajo abierto a mujeres de todos los
colores
[Música]
la capital togolesa Jacques tiene buenas
razones para estar alegre El joven
diseñador fundador del Festival
Internacional de la moda de todo se ha
propuesto que el certamen Encarna los
valores de la diversidad
creo que es una cuestión global porque
durante mucho tiempo la gente que se
parece a nosotros simplemente se ha
escondido no ha querido presentarse este
tipo de eventos ni involucrarse en
situaciones en las que tuvieran que
subir al escenario y ser vistos Y espero
de verdad que este tipo de cosas
empiecen a cambiar empezó con Álex y
quizá yo siga sus pasos junto con otras
personas Alex usted que es un poco mayor
que Kim qué consejo puede darle
siempre le he dicho a quien que vaya por
lo suyo que salga de las Sombras y sea
él mismo siempre esté donde esté tanto
si hablamos del día a día como de un
evento concreto siempre tiene que ser el
mismo
es cierto que es difícil salir a diario
y enfrentarse a un entorno que es hostil
A quién eres y a las identidades que
muestras al mundo pero tenemos que
perseverar en la lucha por ser nosotros
mismos porque al fin y al cabo lo que
cuenta es ser feliz con tu vida Eso es
lo más importante lo que piensen los
demás es su problema hoy Alex lleva un
look masculino y Kim uno femenino estoy
provocando el escándalo del siglo Pero
no importa el escándalo del siglo Por
qué
es una broma aquí lleva una colección de
que me encanta y que se inspiró en una
historia increíble sobre el matrimonio
en el mundo creo que voy a representar
bien esta colección
es una diseñadora la que le encanta
cuestionar el status quo y también
celebrar los matrimonios cuanto menos
convencionales mejor
leían alguna parte que este año se
celebraron más de 250.000 matrimonios
así pues parece que el matrimonio está
lejos de estar muerto a pesar de lo que
podamos pensar Así que por qué no
aportar Mi pequeña contribución a la
institución poniendo algunos looks de
novia no tradicionales quería ropa que
inspirara Aventura ropa que dijera esto
es un viaje
este año independientemente de los unos
o los otros varios diseñadores han
encontrado Inspiración en el atuendo
nupcial una nueva tendencia que también
se traduce en más negocio trabajo con un
material muy fluido es muy ligero es un
tejido muy ligero que las mujeres llevan
en el desierto para mantenerse frescas
trabajo sobre cuerpos masculinos para
intentar sacar a relucir el lado más
femenino de los hombres la esperanza es
que haya un lado femenino en los hombres
que pueda Resaltar en esta colección
se tiende a fomentar intenta sacar el
lado femenino de un hombre
Sí cada hombre viene de una mujer no se
puede decir que un hombre tiene una
determinada realidad mientras Ignora el
lado femenino no se puede hablar solo de
una parte de lo que somos hay que
celebrar las dos y eso es lo que quiero
Resaltar en esta colección
[Música]
este año mi colección se centró en una
pareja de novios concretamente en una
boda en el sultanato de Fondant en
Camerún un lugar al que le tengo mucho
cariño es una cultura tan rica que se ha
conservado muy bien así que este año mi
colección se llama Batman el matrimonio
de Tambora y es realmente una boda de
estas culturas camerunesas tengo una
hermana que pertenece a esa cultura y se
llama tamura Y más allá del aspecto
artístico también está el económico el
desarrollo del continente intentamos
aportar nuestro granito de arena
todo es un poco como en las noches
árabes pienso en la mujer africana que
participa en esa ceremonias marroquíes y
africanas
porque hay algunos pequeños mensajes en
mi colección y también hay un toque de
influencia magrebí que para mí es un
guiño a esa cultura argelino marroquí
que he intentado incorporar a mis looks
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que mi
familia Tengo una sobrina marroquí que
se ha casado recientemente con un chico
argelino
quería destacar ambas culturas y Mostrar
que estamos Unidos
venimos de la misma familia
y esta familia de diseñadores está de
acuerdo en una cosa comparten el amor
por el saber hacer sartorial y el
Ingenio
cuando era joven y me iniciaba en la
moda me encantaban los vestidos de dior
y balenciaga sobre todo los de dior y me
di cuenta de que la silueta es casi como
ingeniería se crea a partir de los
huesos de la forma en la que están
hechos Así que aprendí deliberadamente
hacer corsetería e intenté incorporarla
a mis vestidos porque quiero que mis
clientes luzcan lo mejor posible que se
sientan seguras de sí mismas
que se sientan guapas que se sientan
elegantes con mis vestidos
y no tienen que preocuparse por la ropa
interior nadie lleva sujetador con mis
vestidos
todo toda la construcción todo el
soporte está dentro del vestido
este año el Festival Internacional de la
moda de todo celebra su dé